after Hugh young deemed sabine's
lightsaber skills lacking Ahsoka decides
to take her training to a higher gear
with a mind-tone in combat training
technique she calls zaduchi this turns
out to be a true Star Wars staple the
Blindfolded training technique that made
its debut all the way back in 1977 Star
Wars when Obi-Wan Kenobi used it to
train Luke Skywalker ahsoka's version of
Satoshi involves a similar helmet but
instead of whipping out a training
remote drone she grabs a wooden sword
and faces off against Sabine herself
Sabine starting from the beginning she
used to use the darksaber talk about a
downgrade Star Wars has never shied away
from depicting the Jedi as space Samurai
and there's that tochi technique is yet
another of this episode's references to
Japanese culture the name is a nod to
the classic blind swordsman zatoichi
Rogue one character chirit imway is
essentially a zatoichi XP in a Sci-Fi
setting there's a cherry on top of the
Samurai cake the training sword Sabine
in Ahsoka use resemble bokin Japanese
wooden swords